teror grp is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
purgy we can agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PE on censored the pope
accuses Israel of terrorism in Gaza AS
Global criticism of the IDF intensifies
I'll put the big questions to government
advisor Mar regev and will debate should
Israel's allies now demand a
ceasefire also tonight David mammo is a
pullet surprise when in playright a
Titan of tinsel town he says diversity
obsessed Hollywood has completely lost
the en jooy me
[Music]
live live from the news building in
London this is Pier Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan uncensored throughout the long
and deadly history of Israel's Wars with
Palestine it's usually Fallen to
Israel's friends to tell them when it's
time to stop that time may be fast
approaching again even as Israel insists
it needs more time to eradicate Hamas it
can only have itself to blame this
weekend the IDF admitted to killing
three of its own hostages in Gaza the
men were waving a white flag of
surrender they'd use scraps of food to
scroll SOS desperately pleading for help
regardless of whether they were Israeli
or Palestinian there is no justification
under international law for killing them
to clear breach of the Rules of
Engagement what does that tragedy tell
us about the way Israeli soldiers are
treating Palestinian civilians how
seriously should we now take Israel's
insistence is doing everything it can to
keep innocent people alive in a separate
incident two innocent women were
reportedly shot dead by sniper fire at a
Catholic Church in Gaza one of them was
leaving the church shelter to go to the
toilet Cardinal Vincent Nichols the
Archbishop of Westminster one of
Britain's most senior spiritual leaders
was scathing it's certainly a
coldblooded killing Israeli Defense
Force says didn't happen wasn't there
well I think that's hard to believe
frankly because uh the people in Gaza
and the Cardinal Archbishop of Jerusalem
they're not given to tell
lies so you don't believe the Israeli
Defense Force no I
don't well the pope went even further he
said that what Israel is doing in Gaza
now constitutes terrorism unarmed
civilians are being bombed and shot at
and this has even happened inside the
Holy Family Parish complex where there
are no terrorists but families children
and sick people with disabilities nuns
some say it's terrorism it's War yes it
is war it is
Terrorism the British government is
Shifting its position to foreign
secretary Lord Cameron in a joint
statement with his German counterpart
said he backs a sustainable ceasefire
and said that too many civilians have
been killed Ben Wallace the influential
Former Defense secretary said Benjamin
Netanyahu thinks a killing rage will
Rectify matters and he's very wrong his
methods will not solve the problem in
fact I believe his tactics will fuel the
conflict for another 50 years his
actions are radicalizing Muslim youth
across the globe I think he's right all
this after President Biden accused
Israel of indiscriminate bombing the
starkest warning yet that America's
backing is not unconditional well news
reports about the war in Gaza today will
state that 18,000 Palestinians have been
killed so far according to the Hamas run
Health Ministry and the key point about
that often quoted sentence is not the
debate about whether Hamas exaggerates
those figures is that Hamas is still in
charge and able to release them as
official numbers after two months of War
endless atrocity ities and the full
might of Israel's Army Unleashed on Miss
tiny strip of land the very people that
supposed to be eradicating are still
firmly in power only about 20% of Hamas
terrorists so far even if you accept IDF
figures on this have been killed 80%
remain alive and fighting well most
civilized countries and decent people
back Israel's fundamental right to exist
and indeed its duty to defend itself but
the war is now starting to look like
more at retribution than strategy that
suspicion is fueled by hardliners
netanyahu's government and by Israeli
commentators making appalling remarks
like
this I support the war crimes he laughs
as the other presenters laugh as well
well the rest of the world does not
support war crimes and if Israel does
have a plan and proof that is working it
needs to start showing the evidence of
that plan very soon we're joining me now
as the senior advisor of Benjamin
Netanyahu Mark Reger Mr Reger thank you
uh for joining me uh in the last two
hours a letter from a number of
conservative members of parliament has
gone to the foreign secretary David
Cameron in which they're demanding that
the UK no longer abstain of resolutions
calling for ceasefires at the UN and
saying thousands of bodies lie under the
rubble in particular number of women and
children have been killed is profoundly
shocking too many Palestinians have died
and then this key line by any measure we
are witnessing a catastrophe of
precisely the kind the 1949 Geneva
conventions were supposed to prevent uh
what is your response to
that I think they're wrong I think
Israel as you said correctly appear
Israel is acting to defend itself to
destroy a a a brutal and ruthless and
horrific enemy uh Hamas which is guilty
of the most terrible crimes against
humanity and our challenge here is is to
to dismantle hamas's military
capabilities when Hamas of course embeds
itself amongst the civilian
population in in in neighborhoods in
hospitals in schools uh in mosques and
so forth even in un facilities and so
we're trying to be as surgical as is
humanly possible in a very combat
situation let me interrupt you there if
you if I may because you say you're
being Surgical and you always say this
that you're being very precise very
careful not to kill civilians but in the
last two days alone we've seen three
Israeli hostages who had no Shon who had
a self-made SOS Banner that they were
holding uh they were clearly not
terrorists and they were shot dead by
Israeli forces and then we have these
two women killed outside a Catholic
church and that the pope has called
terrorism based on his information that
he's got from the Archbishop in in
Jerusalem this is I'm afraid not
indicative of a fighting force that is
trying to be surgical or precise it is
actually lending uh I would say support
to the notion that President Biden put
out that it's
indiscriminate so let's let's talk about
those two issues specifically let's
start with the the the three hostages
who were tragically killed you know the
fighting in Gaza in that particular part
of Gaza has been very tense close
quarter combat face to-face fighting and
it's it's very difficult and it our
soldiers claim and this is being
investigated of course that obviously
they perceive the three as a threat
incorrectly and tragically you know in
all sorts of urban Warfare you you have
what the experts called Blue on on
Blue they were shooting waving a they
were waving a white a white piece of
cloth with SOS
you know they were clearly not Hamas
terrorists unless you've been killing a
number of Hamas terrorists you've been
waving white cloths with SOS and
surrender on them which I don't think
you have these these people were killed
and they were turned out to be Israeli
hostages I mean it's an absolute tragedy
um but to Simply dismiss it as sort of
Blue on Blue it seems to me it wasn't an
accident they were deliberately killed
and they were literally holding a cloth
saying SOS I mean it's hard to think
they were more blatant more blatant
killing of innocent people than this
isn't it it it's worse than blue and
blue because they are civilians there
weren't even combatants yes and they
were were you know they were freeing
obviously running away from Kamas uh one
of our problems in this was was the
soldiers on the ground did not have a
briefing that they could expect to see
hostages walking down the street so to
speak uh we expected to see hostages in
tunnels in dark room rooms imprisoned
and the idea that they'd be walking
around uh somehow free was was was a
surprise and why anybody holding an SOS
Banner would they shoot a Palestinian
that was doing that a Palestinian your
assumption your assumption which could
be correct Pierce but it also might be
incorrect is that the soldiers who fired
the shots saw all that and this has to
be investigated obviously when it was
over they all this was discovered but we
have to find out and has to be
investigated what did the soldiers see
at the time it's clear that they
perceived that this was a
threat and we know that there was
fighting in that area there was uh uh
there was hostile fire from the location
more or less where the where the three
were coming from both before and after
this tragic event so we have to
investigate we have to get to the bottom
but I can tell you this the the chief of
staff of the Israeli military the most
high senior officer in uniform he uh he
spoke publicly earlier and and he said
very clearly of course that the idea of
shooting someone who is way you know
holding a white flag and and and so
forth that is that is against our code
that's the against our Rules of
Engagement he was crystal clear and he
even stressed he even stressed it it's
not connected to them being hostages
even if they had been Gaz and
Palestinians that would have been wrong
Behavior against our code of conduct and
let me explain why for two reasons one
for moral reasons it's against it's
against the morality of the army but
also from a tactical point of view
because if you can take prisoners uh
then you get information you get
intelligence in other words the idea so
it was obviously it has to be
investigated but the the chief of star
said clearly this is against our code of
conduct what happened to the ID soldiers
who fired the
bullets so there there's an
investigation going on and from have
they been withdrawn from the from the
battlefield well well first of all we
have to see what the investigation comes
out how do you investigate if they're
still out there fighting have you have
you brought them back no I'm sure the in
the ways the military does these
investigations is always very thorough
because we want to learn the lessons and
let's be frank the families of the three
people to be clear do do you know if
they're still in active fighting or the
soldiers or whether the soldiers
responsible have been
withdrawn I I don't have the answer that
question I simply don't know I can ask
the military and get you an answer
surely you would agree with me it'd be
pretty extraordinary if they're still
out there having committed this atrocity
it's what it is it's a tragedy it's also
an atrocity three hostages who were
literally fleeing for their lives to
what they thought was the safety of
their own side have been just killed in
Cold Blood having held a sign up saying
SOS I mean at the very least I think the
world would expect that the people
concerned who fired those bullets have
been withdrawn from active service until
this is properly
investigated so once again I ask the IDE
but I can say the following that there
was no attempt at all to try to hush
things up we we openly admitted this the
Army came straight out and spoke to the
families and said this was a terrible
accident and it will be looked into and
there'll be a thorough investigation and
the and the and the evidence and what
the investigation reveals will be shared
with the families of the three hostages
who who who were killed uh we're going
to be uh the Army is going to be very
transparent on what's happened here we
owe it to ourselves so these things
don't happen again and we owe it to the
families are you going to be as
transparent about what happened at the
Catholic church that the pope described
as an act of terrorism and given the
Archbishop of Westminster says he simply
doesn't believe the IDF when it claims
it didn't do
it so we'll investigate that as well we
are in the process of doing so uh uh
we're we're looking at the situation
closely if your snip did
it we we at the moment yes I I can say
the following our for forces do not
deliberately Target civilians we
definitely don't deliberately Target was
it IDF snipers who fired the bullets so
once again we don't this is still being
investigated but I can say the following
Pierce we don't deliberately Target
Civ respect Church we're talking about
two incidents where that's exactly
what's happened and why it's happened is
crucially important to the credibility
of The Wider statements that you've been
making on behalf of the Israeli
government about whether you are being
indiscriminate that's why it's so
important and again I just ask you a
simple question you must know you knew
immediately you'd fired the bullets that
killed the hostages you must equally
have known immediately whether your
snipers have shot these two women
outside the Catholic Church you
literally just have to ask the question
so this was this happened this happened
over the weekend you must have had
enough time now to establish was it
Israeli snipers because earlier today
you were denying it denying the
suggestion it may have been IDF but the
Archbishop says that's a lie so what is
the situation with with these
killings so so let me please answer by
saying what needs to be said it's not
like someone is R is hanging around with
a gun and and indiscriminately shooting
we're talking about combat zones where
where question was whether did IDF
soldiers shoot those two women you know
the answer it's it's still be looking
into and I'm sure that we'll be putting
out a report I can't prejudge the idf's
report beerus you understand that but
you've already prejudged hang on you've
already prejudged the killing of the
hostages and said you know for a fact
you did that why do you not know for a
fact you killed these two women or not
because we had the bodies here of the
three and there was immediately shown to
be CH I'm not sure we've got the bodies
of the two women I don't know where they
are I I don't know what the situation is
we will get to the bottom it just it
wasf who who who who were these snipers
who two women outside a Catholic Church
in Gaza would because we know there was
fire there this you see the way it's
being presented incorrectly is that
somehow there was people at a church
going to pray or praying and and
suddenly the IDF came and attacked no
that wasn't the situation Pierce we know
there were firefights in that area we
know our forces took hostile fire so
it's quite possible that it was Israeli
forces but it's also possible it was
bullets from the other side but I think
I'm sorry but you are stretching my
credulity to try and make me think you
don't know the answer after all this
time given how clear you've been about
the other incident an IDF C I'm sure a
full IDF report will come out shortly
and I urge you please be patient it's
it's worthwhile waiting for the full
report and if it transpires as everybody
believes and as the Archbishop of
Westminster said had come directly from
information on the ground that he
believed was credible uh related to him
by the Archbishop of Jerusalem and what
the pope himself has called an act of
terrorism if that turns out to be indeed
the work of the IDF again what would
your response be
so I can give you from the P an example
from the past Pierce uh where there was
a situation on the beach in ba in Gaza
this was in one of the pre previous
rounds of of conflict and I remember it
well because I was personally inv I
don't want to go into previous incidents
it doesn't because I'm giving you I'm
giving you president the pope has
directly accused you of
terrorism no but I do think I do think
it's incumbent on the on you as a
government to very very very quickly
tell the world what happened here citing
previous incidents in previous Wars and
conflicts is kind of meaningless frankly
I mean no but but I'm but I but judge us
by our track record because in the past
we have come clean when there was an
accident and we we Mis misidentified a
Target and we killed itent people and
that's what I'm starting to tell you we
have come and admitted that we've made a
mistake you must know if you had snipers
in that area by that church who shot
people you must know that but if there
was a firefight and there were shooting
from both
sides we have to look into this ham
terrorist there were Hamas terrorist
just to be clear your position is there
were Hamas terrorists inside a Catholic
church with a bunch of location I didn't
say that I said in the location in
location of the church when do you think
and they were firing at our people and
our forces return fire if it turns out
as the pope has has alleged uh and if
fact stated as fact it was act to
terrorism what will Israel do about that
but can can I say the following which I
don't accept in the accusations I can
accept the possibility that they were
killed unintentionally caught up in the
crossfire I do not accept that they were
deliberately targeted by the IDF we do
not Target civilians we do not Target
churches right and terrorism definition
of terrorism the terrorism with respect
the deliberate targeting of the innocent
yes I know unfortunately in the last 48
hours you have shot and killed three
Israeli hostages and it is believed IDF
forces have also shot and killed two two
completely innocent women outside a
Catholic church so this constant refrain
that you're not targeting innocent
civilians is not borne out by the
reality of IDF forces targeting and
killing innocent
civilians no but no I disagree and if
you'll allow me to finish the sentence
please peers there's a huge difference
between a policy that deliberately
targets civilians that's what Kamas does
yes and between civilians inadvertently
getting caught up in the crossfire
between combatants between the Israeli
forces you call it Crossfire but the
allegation is that all five of these
victims were deliberately shot dead the
two women by snipers and the three by in
the first place no let's be clear if
there was a trial right let's let's say
the accusation against the soldiers who
killed the three hostages it wouldn't be
a murder trial it would be a trial if
there was a trial and I don't know there
will be yes but but they would be
accused of negligence or of not
misidentifying a Target yes murder and
terrorism is the deliberate targeting of
the incident I understand and it's not
clear that in either of these cases that
applies right but it may well be that
that's what what happened you can't rule
that out either well that's why you've
got to do an
investigation right but you know it
shouldn't take very long to ask whether
you had snipers in that area you shot
women outside a church but I'm I know
for a fact we had combatants in the area
but the the fact is did they in fact
fire the bullets that killed the two
women once again let wait for the
investigation and as I said in the past
when we've made mistakes we have
admitted it there's a track record there
I you remember I want to to show you a
picture this is of uh uh IDF bombs and
they've inscribed on them the names of
actually a number of people who've been
guests on the show Muhammad hijab Andrew
Tay and also one of my next guests Jen
weager um what is your response to
that maybe IDF soldiers are watching
your show is that possible yeah but do
you think it's uh a sensible thing to be
doing to be putting names like this on
these
bombs well first of all it's obviously
the this is some soldiers trying to be
funny or creative but it there's a
history here going back to the first
world war isn't there not of soldiers
drawing pictures on on on shells and so
forth it's it's something that soldiers
have done I'm not justifying it but I
think British soldiers have done it
sounds like you are justifying it to me
sorry no I'm just putting it into
historical context okay uh Mark reg I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much thanks having me sir well on S next
I'll be putting Mark reg's comments to
US Presidential hopeful Jen weer a major
critic of the IDF whose name as I just
said was Mart on an Israeli
[Music]
bomb we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten another no matter
how well trained most dog owners will
tell you a dog can turn you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swearing off in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
him three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald's MC mous man MC mous
man m m he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not do an
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call teror group is it
possible to have a rational I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and their terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that
welcome back to on sensor demands for
full ceasefire are now growing across
the world one of my next guest J yugar
has been among the loudest voices
calling for one his name was written on
an Israeli bomb to be dropped on Gaza
along with that of Andrew Tate Muhammad
hijab all previous po Palestinian guests
on this show well I'm joined Now by
Democratic presidential candidate Jen
yug got masab Hassan yusf the son of the
Hamas co-founder shik Hassan yusf m is
opposed to terror group since defecting
in the 90s and the former Chelsea at
Israel manager abam Grant joins me live
in the studio a great to see you and
I'll come to you in just a moment uh Jen
I want to start with you because pretty
extraordinary to see your name scrolled
on a IDF bomb just first of all what was
your response to
that yeah uh it's of course
disheartening to see it it's sick uh
they're going to drop those bombs on
Palestinian civilians they're probably
going to murder babies and and
grandmothers with those bombs that's why
if I'm president I won't send Israel a
single dollar not not only the $14
billion they're considering now but I
would end all funding to Israel as they
have massacred civilian after civilian
19,000 dead 9,000 children butchered I
do not want a single American Tax dollar
going to help Israel commit war crimes
and if they think they're going to
intimidate me by putting my name on on
their bombs they've got another thought
coming to them where a state in this war
where Hamas is believed to have around
35,000 uh
terrorists uh at best estimate 7 to
8,000 if you accept the Ida figures have
been killed and that's not been
confirmed at all but if that is the case
that's only 20% of the total that means
that 80% of herass terrorists have not
been killed yet uh again I'm staying
with you Jen for this I mean if your
Israel and your mission statement is to
eradicate Hamas the calls for ceas far
are going to fall on deaf ears aren't
they because they're determined as we
can hear from all the rhetoric to finish
the job as they see it
yeah so let's be clear I mean I saw the
mark regon before me uh the propagandist
for Israel that you had on and uh first
of all he thought it was funny that my
name was on the bombs I don't think that
the children that they murdering uh
think it's funny uh and the idea that
they are not indiscriminately killing
civilians is absurd so they dropped
2,000 lb bombs in residential areas
America never Dropped a Bomb larg than
500 lbs in a residential area in Iraq
and we did great damage in Iraq four
times larger the area is the size of Las
Vegas and they've dropped
29,000 bombs nearly half of which are
unguided missiles then they shoot three
hostages uh dead without even checking
when they had a white flag and no shirt
on at all and if those three hostages
were Palestinians instead of Israelis no
one would have even noticed CU now at
this point one more devastating fact
Hamas and what they did on October 7th
was terrible and they killed 846
civilians the rest Were Soldiers now
Israel has even if you take the IDF
numbers of saying that there's they K of
the 19,000 they killed is 5,000 they
claim is Hamas it's an absurd number a
total and utter lie not backed up by any
evidence but even if you accepted it
that means Israel has now killed 16
times as many civilians as the terrorist
group Hamas here's the question what
does that make Israel should Israel
leave Hamas 80% intact is that good for
anybody so no so now we get to the
absurdity of what Israel says we are
going to stay there until all of hamas's
uh Gone how how do we know if they're
all gone how do we know if they've
surrendered how do we know if the
Palestinians have turned on Hamas these
these are all impossible standards meant
to eradicate uh Gaza entirely and in
fact they've almost done it already 90%
of the people in Gaza are homeless we're
picking out the body parts of family
members every single day in Gaza it is
one of and now that even the New York
Times and every Human Rights group
acknowledges this is one of the worst
massacres the biggest war crimes
committed in our lifetimes American 20
years in Afghanistan did not kill as
many
civilians has killed two months but
should they leave so now let me give you
an answer let me give you a productive
way to do this how to drive Hamas out
you make a peace deal with the
Palestinian author that buys them The
credibility to be able to say to the
Palestinian people we have delivered a
state for you the thing that we have
been looking for our entire lives and
now because we have delivered that for
you we are going to run Gaza that can
drive Hamas out in a way that is organic
and driven by the Palestinians
themselves if you just try to murder as
many civilians as possible in Gaza that
is not an answer for actually getting
Hamas and by the way the bombs have
shown that they do not affect the
tunnels so all they're doing is killing
cilian let me bring in masab ban YF
you're the son of the one of the Hamas
co-founders of course and renounced that
back in the the '90s you believe uh that
uh Israel should finish the job they
should eradicate
Hamas well absolutely because all the
calling for a
ceasefire is calling for surrender they
want Israel to surrender to the
terrorist Savages and sit down at the
table and negotiate with them and this
is absolutely
rejected is there any deal to ever be
done with Hamas you know Hamas very well
obviously through your father is there
any deal to be done with a group like
this
now there is no deal with the devil
there is no deal with Hamas as long as
they pose a
threat uh against children against
civilians and destabilize Security in
the entire region if you if they get
away with their crime and their crime is
not just any crime it's a genocide if
they get away with their crime what will
they do tomorrow they have to be
punished and they have to be held
accountable all the calling forces fire
those are the people who want to give a
Lifeline to Hamas and this is not
acceptable M you tweeted on Friday uh
something that many people found in cury
you said never trust anyone who
identifies as a Muslim they may be may
appear as a harmless sheep when they are
alone but when they're in a pack they
will begin to show their tusks I have
zero respect for any individual who
identifies as a Muslim and I may
consider the use of force when it comes
to islamist what did you mean by that
many people say why would you say that
about you know over a billion
people well I don't care how many they
are any person who put the religious
identity above the the highest interest
of humanity I have no respect for this
people the majority of the musl Muslim
people identified with Hamas supported
Hamas show me how many Muslims out there
who condemned Hamas genocide why because
is it because Jewish
blood this is what I meant that the
Muslims as long as they give Hamas cover
I have no respect for them as long as
identify as Muslims I have no respect
for them but I've interviewed a number
of Muslims on this show who do not
support Hamas and have renounced him Jen
himself came on the show before and
immediately denounced what her with I am
dealing with a majority of Muslim
countries
governments an entire nation don't tell
me about an individual here or or there
we're talking about a majority of Muslim
I'm talking about well I'm only saying
that because fail to take their moral
responsibility fail to take their moral
responsibility because it's Jewish
people understand but you did say
literally every Muslim you said don't
trust anyone who identifies as a Muslim
that's all of them and what I'm saying
to you is I've interviewed many Muslims
on the show who are not extremists who
do not support what Hamas did who
believe what they did was a terrorist
they still need but they still have the
need for a religious identity which is a
false
identity individuality is something else
freedom is something else a person who
know who they are they are above all
national and religious identities there
is no need to pose as a Muslim in a
critical time in the human history this
is the time to take moral responsibility
what's the point of of identifying as a
Muslim while people threatening to
erase uh an entire Jewish
Community this is not acceptable this is
why I want the Muslim to stand and be
clear up to this point I haven't seen I
haven't seen the Muslims taking a moral
stand a a firm stand against Hamas you
know why because they are Muslims
because they are Muslims against the
Jewish people and this is where I want
the to push the Muslims to the point
where they need to stand firmly and say
it doesn't matter if they are Jewish or
Christians a genocide is a genocide and
is rejected Hamas is rejected I want to
see this clearly then after that I will
have respect for the majority of the
Muslim people as long as they fail their
moral responsibility I have no respect
for them okay um you made your point
very firmly that be bring in abam AB
look a lot of emotions run very high
with this understandably a lot of people
have been killed on both sides it's a
horrific situation you were in Israel on
October the 7th you've been back since
you've spoken to IDF soldiers you've
been to the kutes that were attacked you
you I think one of your daughter's
friends was killed I mean you have it's
personal for you you know your your
father survived the Holocaust um what do
you feel about all
this I feel sad to be honest I feel sad
but I want to tell you something I came
to Israel
few days before the atmosphere was very
pic my my son is musician he's writing
songs by the way write a song about the
word that he call it stopper I say why
stoer I said because for me everything
sto in the seventh of
October and then I woke up and Saturday
morning my friend called me say you
don't believe it 23 people was murdered
by the by the Hamas I said oh and he
started to watch a television the there
after my wife wife decided that we will
took our daughter Romy because she was
working in the in the television and you
know I don't know if you know I think
also you got all the videos horrible
videos she didn't want to see it on the
way back my daughter start to cry I say
why say we found a li our friend he was
murdered in the in this party the way
party for peace party for peace not only
by the Jewish
people so this how I exposed to this
situation but I will tell you
it's a traged it's a it's a tragedy all
of this area is tragedy I'm not a
politician I'm a football guy but I live
in this area I have a lot of Muslim
friends I have a lot and I want one
thing to say two things first what would
you do what England would do if this
massacre happened in England what they
would do what they would do they would
be silence and not just this what do we
do if the people that did it say
publicly we will do it again and we will
do it again and they show the videos by
the way all the videos was published by
them was videos by them even the Nazis
was hiding what they do what do you
would do of course you need to prevent
the second time but are you comfortable
Abraham with the scale of the response
by Israel do you feel comfortable now a
lot of people are feeling increasingly
uncomfortable and when you see three
hostages being killed you see women
being killed outside churches the po
calling it terrorism the president of
the United States saying it's it's
indiscriminate bombing and so on do you
feel comfortable about this do you think
that Israel should just carry on or do
you think they should have a pause I'm
not a general of all things I think one
thing everybody know this Hamas not need
to be in this area if the Hamas is not
here if the hostage will release by the
way which hostage is 10 months years old
four years old 85 years old your people
that was in the party it's not the
soldiers they didn't fight it's un never
I don't remember in the history hostages
like this they need to release them
immediately they need to put the weapon
down one thing for sure I can say to you
pe if they would put their weapon down
if they release the hostages and they
put all their efforts instead to build
tunnels instead to make missiles to the
to the I should say to the quality of
the people Gaza can be paradise I can
assure you to this for sure do you think
Israel should continue fighting until
they get rid of Hamas completely or that
could mean many many months if not years
at the rate they're going no I don't
know people say six weeks I don't know I
think this is need to be the target of
the Free World and Israel to get rid of
the Kamas because the Kamas I'm one of
the that believe them not believe that
the number they said we want to kill
again we want to yeah they did there's
no question of that so you need to get
rid of the Hamas you need to get rid how
to do it how to do it I'm a football
coach I'm not everyone talks about the
day after the war what do you think the
future looks like here how do we get to
peace I will tell you exactly not
exactly I will tell you my opinion first
I have a lot of Muslim friend I have a
mus by the way I have a friends in
Gaza my wife even did a program about
family from Gaza I have a friends all
the Muslim around the world they condemn
what's happened they don't like it I
don't agree with this guy I agree with
him that the Hamas is the devil but not
all the Muslims are like this they
didn't like what they do I think I think
the people in Gaza deserve other
government they deserve other leader
they need the leaders that who should
that be they need the lead I don't know
they need the leaders that they from
them leaders that they take care of the
quality of life they need a leaders that
will lead them to the to this they need
a leaders that their target is not to
hate their target is to build something
the target is to do something not to
hate others this deserve one thing for
sure you you know the song of M the
speech I Have a Dream I also have a
dream I have a dream that it will happen
I would tell you
something the leader that admire more
than more than anybody I think is the
number one leader on the 2 cent is Anar
Sadat Anar Sadat was a guy that was the
worst enemy of Israel in 25 years four
Wars one of them he started it yes they
killed each other many people died many
people got injured and this guy came
decided to come to Israel to the
Parliament and say I know I want a peace
and I will tell you something in these
days to say I'm going to Israel it's
more than bad will come to America you
know and he came and what's happened
this since then 50 years nobody died
it's a cold peace I want the peace will
be better nobody died to I'm expect that
these leaders these leaders now in the
Regent and I agree with the son of the
the father will take responsibility and
he said let's make Gaza Paradise you
know that I I try to do a project of
football yeah pitches on the borders and
I will do it by the way pees Israel is
playing Palestinians yeah p and the
people will come to p i I try to do this
project I still believe in this but I
expect this leader maybe it's Muhammad
bin Salman maybe others I expect the
leaders sit together and say instead to
give them money for tunnels why they
need the tunnels why they make money to
the quality of the people like
came to Israel very brave men I expect
them to do this and I will tell you I
will tell you one thing I've got to I've
got to go actually I think you're right
I will put all the leaders together that
want piece even from Iran even everybody
that want pieace and want to make Gaza
parad they can make it and you know how
it started when an saidat called to
water concrete and say to him I'm ready
to come to is so maybe they would call
you peer and they say let's make peace
let's make G I would do anything stop
the intention of killing other people
because I agree with Mark the Israel
never have intention to kill other
people go to leave you there fascinating
to talk to you and great to see you
thank you very much indeed and to my two
other guests I really appreciate it u u
Jake I can see you wanted to jump in we
will come back to this you're a powerful
voice and I will come back to you about
this I've just run out of time tonight
but thank you all very 9,000 dead
children in Gaza
9,000 dead horr children it's acts of
terrorism we'll get you back on again
soon and we'll talk about it again I
promise you that thank you all very much
for joining me on S next to put surprise
winning playwright and screenwriter
who's calling out Hollywood's diversity
Obsession David Mammoth Is Burning
Bridges all over Tinsel Town and good
for him frankly he's live
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know I love love about toour today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Tor love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like mattera and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a living if you're
walking towards me and you're a vegan
you have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegans about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call terror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
welcome back to S my next guest is a
Hollywood screenwriting Legend the
genius behind some of the most memorable
scenes in movie history David mamm is
daring now to call out Hollywood's
diversity obsession with this new book
everywhere and oink oink and embittered
despec and accurate report of 40 years
in Hollywood and he joins me now David
great to have you on the show um I'm so
happy you did this book uh because it
needs to be said loudly Hollywood has
lost the plot in recent years at the
altar of trying to tick endless boxes
for diversity for virtue signaling
whatever it may be and it's made a lot
of movies simply unwatchable and it's
also made award ceremonies unwatchable
as all the actors get forced into making
these homilies and lectures and
statements when all I want them to do is
Embrace
movies yeah well the thing about
Hollywood is it's dead and I've been
around a long long time and and I
technology changes a culture as we see
that the vaille was driven out of
business by the
movies and uh the movies took it in the
tank when television came along and
every time the technology changes
there's a whole new paradigm who are we
to whom are we appealing who's in charge
of that how do we keep track of it and
so forth and so now the new paradigm is
to go to loading and streaming so that
the the incredible
bureaucracy the pointless bureaucracy of
the studio system which has been around
for a hundred years is now dead there's
nobody there who
says think of it this way if somebody at
Kodak said 30 years ago gez I'm young
you guys don't know there's this whole
new thing called computers and
digitalizing we got to stop making film
they would have said to that person
you're out of your mind you're fired
right if we stop making film our share
price goes goes in in the toilet so the
same thing is now true in Hollywood
nobody goes to the movies anymore uh in
the the brick-and mortar movie theaters
and most people are just sick to death
of this garbage that's being stuffed
down their throat by the people who say
buy a subscription or read a book I mean
when we see the issue that Disney got
into for example with Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves where they decided they
weren't going to have any dwarves
because they wanted to take every quot
of box going and stuff the backlash to
that was very interesting to watch for
me it sort of said to me that the main
body of the public have just had enough
of this to a
degree well there's there's nobody
making everybody's making a corporate
decision so corporate so the whole thing
about AI is interesting to me because
that is the apotheosis of what idiots
have been saying for 100 years why don't
we just get people in a room and see
what the audience bought last year and
make it again this year year wouldn't
that make sense well it doesn't make
sense because you can't predict what the
audience is going to like right because
even the people who come out and say
this is what I liked they do that
because they've been asked the question
they've been turned into a Critic so
even though they might say yes I liked
this it doesn't mean they're going to
like it again next year so what what's
missing from Hollywood is individual
invention which can only come from the
individual and courage to take a chance
and say yeah you know what I'm going to
do this story because it's fun rather
than I'm going to do this story because
if I don't I'm going to get fired who
wants to watch that garbage I get all
these Hollywood screeners in the in the
maril and they're all a deeply felt
understanding tale of a person caught
between his personal idea who who cares
nobody cares what is the answer to this
I mean is there an
answer yeah there's an answer I just
made a movie uh with shyia lauff and
Evan
jite Dom Hoffman and Chris Bower and
they the people who made this movie also
made some direct to downloading movies
among them the peanut butter Falcon and
among them um honey boy with Shia and
also that they just kept made this movie
called sound of Freedom which was I
think funded by some Christians who made
a lot of money with uh Jim cisel playing
Christ now he plays a cop it's a
straightup cop movie starring Jim cisel
they made it for $8 million they made a
quarter of a billion dollar because they
went right to downloading to people who
said you know what heck I'll pay money
for that this is a great business if you
think about it if you make a movie for
say $2 million and you download it and
it makes $4 million which you can do if
you just threw it out the window you
just doubled your investment in three
months yeah this is a so that that's
what's happening now what has been the
reaction David to to your book from
Hollywood the reaction to my book I
don't know about Hollywood but the the
critical reaction has been uh
overwhelmingly this is hysterically
funny thank you thank you thank you
that's that's good enough by me as far
as Hollywood goes it's kind of an a um
it's kind of like World opinion right
it's the mob it doesn't quite really
exist and uh so as far as Hollywood goes
that's my answer what I did in the book
because I've been in this business for
for for 40 years in every aspect of it
sitting at the big table so what I'm
saying is this this is what actually
went on that most people who write tell
all books are either um settling a
grudge or exculpating themselves or or
hyping their brand but I said you know
what I've had so much fun in this
business here's a bunch of funny uh and
runchy stories I hope you like it and
the reaction's been uh gratifying I tell
you it is I mean I'm no surprised I love
all your work but it is absolutely
hilarious and I'm so happy you've done
this book everywhere in ooink an
embittered despec and accurate report of
40 years in Hollywood everyone should
just go and read this a for a great
laugh and B to see the veneer of this
[__] blown away so David thank you
very much indeed for joining me you're
so welcome thank on Su the next the Pat
will be with me in the
studio
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online run
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
SP today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David camon I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and rishy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
of money it's cost we're saying what are
we saying it's cost about 140 million
£140 million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan should have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC M man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes CU I cannot continue my
work when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions are you prepared to call
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
[Music]
wel back joined by my Pat talk to
contributor EST CKU and the political
journalist AA s welcome ladies let show
you a little haircut Eve Gilles Miss
France the winner of Miss France who
apparently is at the center of a woke
backlash because she has a pixie hairo
and the friend like their Miss France
winners to have long hair and she's the
first Shorthair one to ever win I don't
get this what's he going to do with woke
she looks fantastic doesn't she am I
missing something most people don't know
how strict the M France rules are so to
be in M France you have to be between
the ages of 18 to 24 you have to be 5'
seven you can't have any kids it's one
of the strictest it's one of the
strictest beauty pageant in the whole is
there a wrong about your hair no they
don't have a WR what's got to do with
wokery well but I mean I'm the biggest
woke basher in Britain but even I am I
cannot Master any anger about a haircut
The Daily Mail tried to jump on it this
morning and they did put it on their
woke watch and I think there was a
slight retraction there was a bit of
edit of an online C thought she looked
fantastic she does I mean I think she
should go for a side part it's a bit too
Linda Evangelista I mean she should go
for more like Hal Berry but I think it's
beautiful looks like Twiggy back in the
60s if you had like a Mis France from
Martinique she'd probably have an afro
right is that it probably be short is
that woke um it's nothing to do with
work is it um let's just anyway well
done Miss France you look fous France
iser having pick our woke battles and
that haircut is not a hill I want to die
on in my woke bashing campaign nothing
do a woman at least she's a woman that's
at least she's a woman not you're right
she's not there's no bulge to be
seen let's talk about um lady moan Melle
moan because I watched that interview at
the weekend I don't think you did her
any favors the big question now should
she obviously it's a criminal
investigation but should she remain in
the house of laws having admitted lying
to the press in which she followed up
with lots of Lial threats yeah if people
publish the truth like I mean I don't
know about you but I'm relieved that I'm
not her lawyer I think her lawyer is
probably somewhere in a dark corner
crying hysterically because should she
be removed from the Lords no look but I
mean there's not there's not a process
to remove someone from the Lords but
it's a good question about whether we
should just get rid of the entire
institution all together and I would
back that all right I think we should
blow it up with a hand what about her in
particular oh yes of course she should
resign if she has a a modicum of of see
I think lying to the Press like that by
sending endless legal threat
is actually lying to the public it is
I've known Michelle a long time right
but I watched that and it had a touch of
the prince Andrew delusion about it it's
like do you not realize that you're
lying to the public and you can't do
that if you're a member of the House of
Lords anyway I love you to see I know
you're sick go back to bed cuz you need
you need to go back to bed and recover
all right care about you Esther that's
it for me whatever you're up to keep it
unscensored and UNS sniffling T
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak so well
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had boost Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique Khan we're
not stopping until you stop the amount
of time it's taken the number of illegal
migrants currently sent by us to Rwanda
zil the amount of money it's cost we're
saying what are we saying it's cost
about 140 million 140 million P so far
so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got a
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film do you think
people underestimate how important music
is for this country it's about 10 times
the size